ouais Dany Boon l'acteur français qui
fait pas l'actualité de la meilleure
déménage puisqu'il serait épinglé pour
un montage fiscal à cause d'un yacht ce
mercredi Canard Enchaîné dévoilé les
dessous de l'achat et de la remise en
forme de son voilier de luxe et voilà
c'est regarder vous allez voir on vous
explique tout ça il y aura Myriam
Palomba Alexandre canoillon fils tech
fiscaliste qui sera avec nous c'est
parti allez
c'est l'un des acteurs préférés des
français je suis Dany Boon comédien mais
l'homme derrière de nombreuses comédie à
succès vient aujourd'hui d'être épinglé
par une enquête du canard enchaînée si
Dany Boon s’était par le passé dit ravi
de payer ses impôts en France il aurait
selon l'hebdomadaire réaliser un montage
fiscal pour financer un yacht de
plusieurs millions d'euros des
révélations qui ont fait bon dire
quelques personnes je trouve ça honteux
alors que lui est-il reproché
concrètement quel est le montant de ce
bateau de luxe combien aurait-il
économisé dans cette affaire et surtout
sa démarche serait-elle légale Dany Boon
épinglé pour un montage fiscal à cause
d'un yacht que s'est-il passé
de TVA concernant l'achat de ce yacht
alors tout le monde en fait un énorme
problème est-ce que c'est vraiment un
problème ou est-ce que c'est légal alors
on a vous alors c'est légal c'est un peu
c'est un peu compliqué est-ce que c'est
les c'est légal si le bateau qui clignot
européenne dans les six mois après son
enregistrement sous le pavillon
d'Antigua et la deuxième condition c'est
que le propriétaire du bateau demande un
certificat d'importation dans le premier
port Europa où il faisait escale bon
c'est un peu compliqué visiblement le
canard haché enchaîné à qui a contacté
les avocats de Dany Boon n'a pas
vraiment eu de réponse sur ces deux
conditions pour que ça soit légal et
quoi qu'il arrive le le Dany Boon aurait
dû auraient pu payer en tout cas
cette TVA s'il avait été contrôlé à la
douane d'accord donc est-ce que c'est
légal ce qu'a fait Dany Boon ou pas
Alexandre canoillon vous êtes avocat
fiscaliste alors non seulement c'est
parfaitement légal c'est un schéma qui
est finalement assez couramment appliqué
quand on parle de ce genre de navire qui
a pas de problème en plus il y a aucun
problème non seulement un légalement il
a rien fait de mal mais l'administration
fiscale française ne lui reproche
absolument rien d'accord pour
l'administration
mais qui lui est tombé dessus le Canard
Enchaîné mais en même temps prenez
l'article du Canard Enchaîné qui est bon
honnêtement fait quelques lignes c'est
pas grand chose qui nous dit plusieurs
bêtises il nous dit que antiga et barbu
c'est un paradis fiscal qui est sur la
liste des États non coopératifs pas
toujours là après la fiscalité c'est
compliqué
et épinglé pour l'optimisation fiscale
déjà parc avait
oui l'optimisation oui mais si vous
voulez comme il est plutôt du genre à
donner des leçons aux gens à dire il
faut voter ça il faut voter ceci il faut
faire ceci il faut faire cela faut vous
allez encore m'en vouloir faut se
vacciner faut pas se vacciner etc du
coup c'est vrai que pour les Français
d'avoir quelqu'un optimisation fiscale
d'animaux bah en fait déjà il multiplie
les résidences à l'étranger les
résidences fiscales donc il y a un
espèce de flou ben voilà il a en
Belgique aux États-Unis en à Londres etc
ensuite selon Mediapart il aurait
demandé à ses avocats de ne pas être
alpha que son que le fils que français
ne commence à peine ne prélève pas sur
son héritage donc ça aussi c'est quand
même assez bizarre et puis il se dirait
qu'il investit aussi dans des fonds
qu'on appelle des des fonds qui sont un
peu des fonds couvertures à part entrer
dans des trucs un peu compliqués mais
qui sont en fait des fonds qui ont qui
sont pas réglementés et qui ont pour but
de protéger le patrimoine des gens très
très riches
exactement
c'est parfaitement légal exactement
remplies mais les gars
c'est tout parfaitement légal mais
est-ce que c'est moral c'est la question
pose vraiment bah je suis comme le Diego
Hugo c'est pas parce que c'est pas alors
c'est légal c'est légal de le faire il
joue des failles du système et moi ça me
dérange pas du tout si il a le droit de
de partir 700000 € de TVA de côté pas
les payer mais il paye pas moi peut-être
j'aurais fait pareil je les aurais pas
payé c'est même sûr si je peux le faire
je l'aurais peut-être fait là où ça me
dérange c'est que c'est ces gens-là qui
te donnent des leçons c'est ces gens-là
qui te disent allez voter pour un test
sujet aider un tels et des Intel Fati
vaccinez-vous vaccinez vous pas à la
limite fait des trucs fais ton business
fais ton truc mais ne dis pas aux gens
c'est ce que dit souvent c'est ne dis
pas aux gens qu'est-ce qu'ils ont à
faire c'est ça qui me dérange pas il
aurait perdu son droit il aurait perdu
son droit à la parole monsieur il va aux
États-Unis il va en Belgique il va
partout dans le monde tant mieux il a le
droit mais viens pas donner des leçons
aux Français comment les Français
doivent vivre en France quand ils sont
dans la merde
il pète parce qu'il fait des films en
France
les impôts sur ces revenus il fait des
films
françaises
des impôts à chaque fois il va être payé
une fois
la même somme d'argent si tu gagnes
beaucoup d'argent faut aussi rendre
exactement exactement
sur son Facebook
oui il incite à voter pour Emmanuel
Macron bon voilà je n'ai pas je n'ai de
l'eau soit donner à personne mais
franchement jamais dans aucun pays un
parti d'extrême droite n'a réglé le
problème en imposant une préférence
nationale prouvant au monde entier et à
nous-mêmes que nous sommes toujours dans
le pays de la liberté et l'égalité et
surtout de la fraternité donc votre
Emmanuel Macron donc ça a été épinglé
lors des régionales 2015
voilà il a aussi pris parti en 2014
qui se présentait dans dans sa région et
du coup il a demandé à ce que les gens
ne votent pas pour le Front National qui
malheureusement pour lui a gagné alors
juste c'est quoi les autres prises
il avait viré son comptable parce qu'il
lui avait proposé de faire de
l'optimisation fiscale au Luxembourg
donc il est toujours il dit toujours des
belles paroles des belles paroles qui
s'accompagne oui c'est l'ego mais est-ce
que c'est moral ça compte pas ça
s'accompagne pas toujours et puis quand
vous quand vous recevez quand vous
recevez 2,7 quand vous recevez 2,7
millions d'euros comme vous recevez 2,7
millions de subventions pour faire un
film et que vous faites tout pour
échapper à l'impôt en France je suis
désolé légalement bah c'est peut-être
légal mais en tout cas vous faites tout
pour y échapper excusez-moi ça peut
déranger les gens
on changerait pas si tu étais beaucoup
plus riche on va parler derrière c'est
bon c'est bon merci donc l'info c'est
que Dany Boon il a fait quoi il a fait
une optimisation fiscale donc rien de
oui il a fait de l'optimisation fiscale
mais c'est légal
après s'il a vraiment investi sur des
les fonds de couverture qui sont pas
réglementées
à Saint-Tropez qui bat pas
on a rien compris
Terminator 28 merci allez à demain
[Applaudissements]